Right now is that we have a lot of
people who want to build brands who want
to become influencers,
who want to start companies,
but they're not putting in the pieces
that actually allowed them to weather
the storm.
You know,
the thing that I'm most proud of is the
two biggest businesses I've ever built.
I basically started them during very
difficult times when I first got
involved in my dad's liquor store
business.
It was the late nineties and just about
a year and a half into my journey,
I guess two years into my journey.
The stock market crashed and all the
Internet companies folded and all the
people that were making money that I was
targeting to sell wine,
stopped having money to buy wine and Ip
and then right behind that,
because most of my business was New York
and New Jersey based.
Even though we were building an internet
company was only about a year later that
nine slash 11 happened.
And not only,
you know,
changed.
I mean for anybody that lived in New
York,
New Jersey area.
It was much more compounded for us
because we lost loved ones.
And I remember I lost 100 employees from
one organization in one day,
I had to go in the hand by hand and take
their emails out because everybody
passed away from Cantor Fitzgerald that
worked in that office so and that.
So I persevered through that because I
was practical because I didn't have a
lot of overhead.
And because I wasn't romantic,
I wasn't dreaming.
I knew that I had a buy and sell wine
and liquor and beer and I had to make
sure that my expenses weren't greater
than the money I was bringing in.
Vaynermedia started in the actions of
the economic meltdown of the U.
S when I started Vaynermedia,
people didn't want to pay $5,000,
let alone the 50 or a hundred thousand.
They pay us a month now for our
services.
And,
and when I started vayner media,
you know,
it's funny,
I watch everybody watched my journey
now.
And you know,
there's that cliche thing of like
overnight success,
right?
I'm going to have this TV show come out
this June and it's going to change my
profile,
right?
I'm going to sit on the stage with will
I am and Gwyneth Paltrow,
Jessica Alba for this apple show that
I'm about to do,
and everybody's gonna say,
where do you come from that happened
overnight and you know,
and it's even really happened in social.
I'm sure a lot of you,
for a lot of you,
you've only really even have known about
me for the last six months or so even
though I had been putting out content
online for 10 years every single day.
And so the thing that I've been really
thinking about is practicality,
like vayner media.
Even though I had already built a nice
size business,
it wasn't like I was extracting a lot of
money out of wine library.
And so when age and I started vayner
media seven years ago,
we started it out of a company called
Buddy media is conference room.
For the first two years that I ran
vaynermedia.
We had no rent.
We first worked out of a conference
room,
a conference room.
We then worked out of a coworking space
before the whole.
We work in coworking space revolution
and I bartered my time to help that
company in exchange for a very small
space.
We didn't buy furniture we scrapped and
I'd already made it.
I was already rich and we scrapped.
And so the biggest thing that I want to
implore everybody here today to do is to
take a step back and think about how
fancy are they?
Are you willing to be really,
really,
really ghetto?
Do you really need that chair?
Do you really need that piece of
technology?
Do you really need to fly that class?
Like I just think that we're living
through an incredibly fancy culture of
entrepreneurship,
entrepreneurship and CEO Status is quite
sexy.
People are selling a lifestyle that is
filled with lots of fun and trips and,
and champagne and bikini's and bling,
bling and all sorts of horse shit.
Right?
And,
uh,
and I just think that that era of this
era is going to come to an end somewhere
within the next five years.
And very honestly,
I just don't want a lot of people in
this room that dream to build their own
businesses to have to go work at a bank
or go work at a retail store.
And so I would highly recommend
something that I think is stunningly not
talked about enough,
which is if you're building a business,
you have to be making money.
And so I know that's like a funny thing
to say,
but I think it's important.
I think the other thing that's important
is to shift the context completely the
other way,
which is what is really winning,
right?
Like what is the definition of winning?
And I think we all have different
definitions,
right?
And I think that one of the things that
I also want to say is that I'm getting
scared that a lot of people that are
following my journey here,
me talking about buying the New York
jets and I do aspire to buy a
$3,000,000,000 sports franchise.
I do.
It is what I want.
It's.
You can look at my fifth grade yearbook
long before business was cool.
It's what I want to do,
but I'm awfully scared that it's
pressuring the people that follow me
into trying to achieve things that they
don't necessarily want.
They just think it's the thing you do if
you're trying to be a successful
businessperson.
Let me promise you something.
I know tens of thousands of people.
I know thousands of people extremely
well.
I know hundreds of people deeply.
Well,
there is no correlation between how much
money someone makes and their level of
happiness.
I have friends who make $47,000 a year
and are the happiest people I know their
work life balances on point.
They're part of two soccer teams.
They play video games.
They watch every show they want.
They take two vacations that they
scrapped together and they're freaking
happiest.
Hell and I know tons of people who I
grew up within the silicon valley boom
who have hundreds of millions of dollars
in their bank account and are as
miserable and as lonely and as broken as
you'll ever see.
So I implore all of you to please
reverse engineer and figure out who you
are and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need and what
level of creativity needed.
I promise you one thing,
one thing that will catch you off guard
my should be way more rich.
I leave money on the table every day.
I've left ungodly amounts of money on
the table.
I spend tons of times spending sending
dms and engaging with people and meeting
people randomly and not cashing in.
I actually believe the statement I'm
about to make.
I think that I love the journey and the
game of entrepreneurship so much that I
have subconsciously sabotaged my
financial upside to make sure I can play
this a little longer because I fear if
the numbers keep getting too big,
eventually it will take the fun out of
it.
When you were lucky enough like I am to
actually do something that you love so
much,
do something that puts pressure against
the one thing you care about besides it,
which is the time I spend with my
family,
my family is my whole life and being
this and doing this is the only thing
that cuts into that I couldn't breathe
if I wasn't an entrepreneur.
I didn't breathe when I wasn't an
entrepreneur.
That's the reason I got d's and f's in
school because I just couldn't be me and
I'm not capable of that.
And so I think being here excites me
because I think coming to not la,
San Francisco,
New York,
London is always more fun for me.
It always feels a little more practical.
It always feels like there's a little
bit more chips on the shoulder,
which is what I have,
but I want to remind everybody just
because you didn't grow up with a trust
fund,
just because you don't live in silicon
valley,
the market doesn't care if you're good
enough,
you will win and I hope that you don't.
Thank you.
And if you sit around and ponder,
well,
if I didn't live here or if my mom
wasn't an alcoholic or if I just learned
about this earlier,
or if I had been following this person
earlier,
or if I wasn't born a woman or if I
wasn't born a minority,
if you sit and do that,
you are losing.
You're not wrong.
It's just that business and marketing
and all this doesn't care.
They're just no emotion in the market
like.
And that's it.
And so I think we need to start having
much deeper,
much more serious conversations of
practicality.
You know,
it's fun and I love this space the most,
but I loved it long before it was sexy.
I loved it long before people want to
take selfies with me.
I loved it long before athletes and
celebrities and rappers want it to be
entrepreneurs.
I loved it long before that,
it was my destiny.
It was who I was.
It was how I was wired.
It was the only thing I knew.
That's why the four year old me ripped
flowers out of yards and sold it.
You don't read about being an
entrepreneur at five,
six,
seven,
eight,
and nine.
I didn't jump on this because it's cool
now and it makes me money and I did it
because it's all I ever was and I
implore you,
if you came here to be an entrepreneur,
but this talk allows you to realize
you're really an artist or you're really
a number three in a company because you
bring this level of energy and you don't
want to be a number one because let me
promise you something about being a
number one.
I'm not an entrepreneur.
I'm a firefighter.
My entire life is taken care of.
Crap.
Putting out fires.
Twenty four slash seven,
three 65.
My whole life is this is a problem.
Fix this,
and guess what?
When you're the last line of defense,
there's no blaming your boss.
There's no blaming the logo.
There's no blaming the government.
It's all my fault,
all of it,
and so it's super sexy,
but what's not being talked about is the
friends and acquaintances I have who've
committed suicide in the entrepreneurial
and the last four years because nobody
talks about the downside.
Everybody thinks they're going to be
zucks.
Everybody thinks they're gonna.
Build snapchat.
Go look at the data.
The data shows that the far majority of
this room will not succeed,
not even close to building an actual
business,
and I don't come here to be somber.
I come here to remind you that there's
only one thing you can do.
The only thing you can do that can trump
the moment,
mommy and daddy had sex to make you the
only thing that can trump that.
The only thing that can trump your dna,
the only thing that is controllable if
you want it,
if you want.
This is work.
Thank you.
Only tangible and by the way,
I don't know if you guys have noticed.
I've stopped even funny given the name
of the conference I've started.
I've started using the word work more
than the word hustle just because I want
everybody to understand what we're
really talking about here.
If you've got a big mouth and a lot of
you do here,
search the Hashtag and a lot of you say
ceo,
founder,
owner.
I call that big mouth.
If you've got the audacity to do it,
and,
and so many of you've heard this from me
when I audit you and I do because I'm
curious.
It's how I learn.
People talk a big game.
I especially loved when somebody hits me
up on social,
like Gary V,
you're gonna buy the jets.
I'm going to buy the rams.
You know,
everybody is buying a sports team and I
love and I love to look at what that
person does and then I'll dm that person
and be like,
Yo bro,
nobody,
nobody.
Unless they were a trust fund baby,
ever bought the rams.
When they go skiing for a week when
they're 24,
nobody,
you know,
nobody you know,
nobody you know has become successful
outside of it being given to them from
their family.
Nobody you know has actually created
success without working their face off.
It doesn't exist.
So you can sit and talk about luck and
you can sit and talk about this,
that,
or the other thing.
But I promise you,
the only controllable thing you have is
your work ethic.
So going back to the beginning of my
talk,
you need to deploy serious,
serious self awareness and figuring out
who you are.
I implore you to start matching your
work ethic and your actions to your
mouth.
If you're going to be a billionaire,
you need to realize that most people
that create billion dollars worth of
wealth don't do anything besides work
every single day of their twenties and
thirties.
All of them,
every person that works at Vaynermedia
has taken more vacations in the last 13
months than I did in my entire twenties
and early thirties.
My family went on to family vacations my
entire childhood.
I was married to my wife for five years
before we had a family.
We took two vacations.
It's the price you have to pay if you
want it at the level that I wanted at.
And by the way,
I advise nobody to want it at that
level.
I'm being dead serious.
This is a very true statement.
I think most of you will not believe,
but I'm telling you,
it's the goddamn truth.
If there was a drug that could take some
ambition out,
I would take it.
It is so extreme.
It is all in.
The reason I started daily Vee was to
remind you that I'm out working you,
that when you talk and you're trying to
figure it out,
when you're trying to say,
you're going to be like me,
I want you to see it.
I want you to see every other day,
5:00 AM,
I want you to see everyday midnight,
all of them every day,
always forever.
That's what it takes for what I want.
Good news is between what I want and
what is achievable and it's considered
unbelievably all time.
Happy is a big gap,
so there's plenty of vacation time.
I know tons of people with vacation
time.
I know tons of people with work life
balance.
I know tons of people that do tons of
fun activities and make seven figures,
millions of dollars a year and love it.
I'm playing for legacy.
I'm playing for all time.
I'm looking to impact every generation
that comes behind me because I want to
show that you can build all time,
wealth,
all time.
Greatness doing it the right way and the
old way.
That's what I'm up to,
so please make sure you understand that
and more importantly,
make sure you understand yourself so
that you can reverse engineered that
blueprint and figuring out you fit
within that and then deploy it,
but I promise you,
you will not get there with your big
idea.
I promise you.
Sitting around and saying,
Oh,
I had that idea for uber before uber
did.
Nobody gives a shit.
I've got every idea that's going to be
successful over the next hundred years.
It's all about ai and Vr and ar and
augmented and all this.
I'll give them to you all.
It doesn't matter because most of you
won't execute against it.
The reason I put out all my best stuff
and I'm like,
then I don't charge for it,
is somewhere along the line I realized
that 99 point nine percent of you aren't
going to do anything about it.
You're going to ponder it.
You're gonna get super pumped up when
you watch me say it,
and then three weeks later you're going
to give up because you're not willing to
pay the price.